[Music]
my name is Aaron and Urich I am the
director of product management for data
analytics and I am so delighted to have
all of you here and I have two guest
speakers with me Remi and Sergei who are
gonna join us they've been a fantastic
use case and they're gonna share the
experience with all of you without
further ado I want to talk to you about
a little about our data and what's
happening with the data how many of you
have seen the study by 2025 corridor
data created globally will be real-time
in nature
core of the data that's a lot of data
guys and this is not much time so we got
to think about what we're gonna do to be
ready for real-time data analytics
what's driving this who doesn't have a
cell phone right now that's good no
hands so we're all using you're taking
pictures now it's getting processed
right you've gone through the clouds
you're using it for buying stuff I know
I'm doing it and I know how I'm being
utilized with my data all the
communications we're doing it think
about all the manufacturing where
everybody is doing all the data were
generating at all times
media manufacturing enterprise personal
shopping what-have-you everywhere the
common thread is I want to create a
data-driven organization who doesn't
want to create a data-driven
organization today we have chief state
officers chief digital officer they're
all tasked to establish a data-driven
organization okay let's talk about what
that means we'll keep that in mind right
what happens in this data rich
environments who doesn't buy stuff
online today right when you make a
purchase you probably saw an
advertisement somewhere and then you
decided to go after it you click on it
and then you create some data
either you bought it or you're
considering it if you want it you're
going to ship it you share some of your
information with your Shah whoever the
purchasing that you did it on the other
ends we have the inventory systems in
place for you we have the financial
systems for you so you can make your
payment so you can trade jacket and so
forth in addition all the other
marketing systems are generating data
around it I know this I've been buying
stuff for my younger son he decided to
build his own scooters I never knew
anything about the Axel's different
sizes of axles now I know and all the
targeted ads that I'm getting about it
this is a better product and so forth
I'm trying to help him with that thanks
to you guys what happened they actually
recognized my need they knew what I was
trying to do they knew where I was
making my searches they knew the types
of searches that I made from the
categories all that information is in
there driven by the events that I
triggered take a look at the things that
I evaluated this versus dance take a
look at the decision that I made what I
wanted to purchase what I didn't want to
purchase and how I came to that point
and what I did after I purchased which
happened three times I bought the wrong
thing I send it back it was a whole
event-driven system who is doing the
online gaming today I am NOT one of them
my son's are my older son it turns out
is one of the online gamers he's racing
he's actually pretty good he's not
making enough money yet but he's gonna
get there and this is a big event so
what happens there the time plate which
we limits how much they play during
school days but they the system knows
how much time they're putting in there
how they're progressing is Sogeti
becoming a better driver or not and his
age all the IP addresses all that
information again it triggers all the
backend systems about what we do and how
we deal with it in this case what are
the types of events we're dealing with
did he beat the regular bots is he
really beating people when he raises
online real people how much time is he
spending on that particular game or
whether or not he is talking to his
friends with many products that they
have online are enabled in enabling each
other to really talk to one another and
they decide what they should buy I know
it because I get an alert they just
bought this online using my credit cards
okay how did that happen right but
that's all driven by the events that
we're actually pushing forward so what
happens to my I want to create
data-driven organization maybe I want to
create an event student organization
right that's what we want to get so
maybe that's probably the path that we
want to go to or are they exclusive if
you look at it they're an exclusive one
things the other one I love the
positioning in here take a look at what
we're trying to do with the strategic
vision that actually drives the
operational priorities if I am the CEO
if I am the chief operating officer of a
manufacturing plant I know what I need
to be building I know what I need men
that will really actually help me drive
my priorities tactically operationally
while I am actually driving my strategy
those timelines are different those
characteristics might be common in some
cases from use case use case but
timelines are different sensitivities
are different on the strategic decision
I can actually take my time to do my
segmentation but when I'm actually
buying something I have to make that
decision I have to make sure that I am
targeting the right person yeah everyone
was trying to buy this part for the
scooter I'm gonna pop that one in here
because that's what he's searching for
not something for his wife that's the
decision that we need to get to the
really interesting dynamics going on in
here but both of the decisions that
we're making short-term and long-term
are driven from these sets of data time
is very critical in here time is spent
between what you have decided to buy to
what you buy and how you can actually
add more value is very important and
we're still dealing with the same sort
of data but the scale is different
decision-making is little difference how
do we address this
eversource getting smaller window of
opportunity to turn it into a right
decision
so that purchasing is done decisions are
made critical decisions are made some of
these things
I'm joking in here scooter buying is not
a critical decision but if you're
running and manufacturing plans if
you're running an enterprise every
second matters on every decision that we
make events activation is all about the
speeds suite of analytics speed of
action that's what we're gonna be
talking about this is what we're going
this is what we're seeing throughout the
world how things are moving there now if
you look at the traditional platforms
why are we struggling why is the trend
towards real-time analytics streaming
analytics decision making is happening
yet the current traditional platforms
are not able to do it well one thing we
can't ingest the data fast enough let
alone processing them let alone really
trying to really make the readily
available data into the hands of the
right people and consider all the tool
sets that are out there trying to tap
into the set of data to make a decision
they're best disconnected not really
relevant to our another so when you look
at the enterprise levels and I was a
senior VP of and CTO of GE healthcare at
one point and I know what a large-scale
system globally
means and how you make those decisions
are very important and the need around
ingestion need around having a unified
system for both batch and streaming is
important service architecture is
absolutely important
I'm sure you've all attended some parts
of the service systems a tools having
the right setup tools for the right set
of decisions that you wanna make is
essential and most importantly
flexibility for the users because we
want to enable everyone to become a data
analysis analysts its strategic decision
makers with the tool sets that we have
enhance a little bit about what we're
doing on Google cloud around streaming
analytics and how we're tackling them
service architectures ingestion services
the action stream processing all unified
not one or the other boss with the same
set of code comprehensive set of l
texture tools from your ml tools to
transfer flows to big queries you name
it and all the flexibilities that you
need when I talk about ingestion some of
you may have heard cloud pops up this is
the largest scaleable ingestion system
that you can find and it is very global
and I'll share with you and my partners
in here will share their experience as
well and how they're doing it
dataflow is designed to handle both
batch and stream needs and you do it
only once you code it once you do it for
both of them and that's how we're
designing it and we use all these
internally within the Google family as
well and for all your analysis you can
use your cloud ml you can use your
bigquery we're making it as easy as
possible for you to leverage an open
source this is our in our DNA everything
we do all of our engineers work in the
world of open source if you happen to be
using one of these
the Kafka's the sparks and flings and so
forth they're all there
you can easily come and start using our
tools they're supporters to help you
achieve your real-time analysis world so
on Google clouds for your needs when it
comes to streaming antics you will find
every tenant that makes it a reality for
you service architecture robust and
global scalable ingestion systems
unified streaming and batch services
flexibility for all your users and all
the tools that you need for analysis now
some of you may have seen this slide if
you look at it on the left hand side
look at the amount of time that we had
to spend to add the value we want to get
to a place where we actually providing
insights we are actually providing some
decision-making not really tinker with
all the tunings and do I have the right
set of data in here do I have the right
connectors is it going to scale is it
going to really have the right memories
in place in some cases you run out of
space you run out of memory this is all
done in a very scalable global way
automatically for you on our analytics
platform
all of them are achieved through our
servers platform it is key to your
success
I mentioned pops up take a look at what
you can achieve how many of you have
scales of hunger gigs of seconds for the
performances that you need global scales
and it actually simplifies how you do it
and the way that we do it is it
integrates with the data processing
simply very integrated in the data flow
so that it simplifies your experience
going forward that is key and this is
done in every region globally so you can
actually check that mark and say I can't
access to my data I can manage my events
I can do that scale mentioned data flow
it is done in a way to unify both
batch and stream for you why is it
important because we are already seeing
the shortcomings all the skill sets if
you had to have a skill set who knows
how to deal with batch versus three
you're not gonna be able to scale this
is done it unifies it because batch is
not going away while the streaming is
getting faster and growing faster batch
is not going away
matches there we want to make sure you
can take advantage of balls with one set
of code one set of two sets one set of
skill sets and it is integrated fully
integrated I told you we believe in open
source beam has I'm so proud to mention
in here has wrong the Technology Award
this year for all the abilities that
provided to the community it is helping
you build your use cases with your
language choice to solve your problems
at scale if you haven't started using it
I encourage you to start playing with it
and to end a comprehensive platform from
ingestion to storage to processing to
analysis this is what you will get from
Google cloud when you starts working on
your next-generation problems and real
time problems and streaming problems
some customers and there's ton in here
we're gonna talk about in detail about
the a be tastier in here but go Jack
Okara
hi games recruit these are examples just
within the last six to nine months that
are popping up in here because they are
seeing as soon as they start moving and
bringing their data using our tools
they're seeing the value they are freely
sharing this and I'm so happy to mention
them in here on the stage with for all
of you without stealing your thunder in
the meantime maybe you wanna come next
to me I I want to introduce my partners
in here about Amy tasty they've done a
fantastic job look at the scale guys 25
million sessions per day 50 million
events analyzed for
day and all done in 32 milliseconds this
is a scale now Ram is gonna cover what
they have done and their journey thank
you for joining me here thank you very
much for inviting us I will try and
Sergey and Sergey will try to share
valuing the valuable insight for you
using Google technologies to give you a
bit of context a be tasty is a platform
for marketing and product team in order
to personalize and experiment and to
personalize and to test on website or
mobile apps so we work like web
analytics tool in terms of collecting
data and we apply modification directly
on the website so we need a real time we
need real time technology in order to
act on client website so we will try to
share this experience with you on a
business perspective for me and on a
technical perspective for Sergey so if
you are technical guy just stay here you
will have Sergey Zen and and I hope it
will help you to implement your your
technology just to give you the global
context of our work I would like to
share with you as the most powerful
real-time technology I ever built that
is to say my my daughter you can be sure
that if Baby Bottle comes around you
know it instantly if you take this jokes
apart this child will grow up in a world
that we already called the first
Industrial Revolution so this is a world
where electronics meet biology
biological aspects and made as well
digital aspects Ford used to say that
you can choose any Ford T as long as
it's black
the fact is for the forced industrial
technology we are the opposite of that
we are in a world where consumers have
multi-touch point we are with brands
they are those multi-touch points
through multiple devices so
desktop mobile watch etc they have
communication with the brands through
emails phone through chat bot as well if
your train is delay you will send a
twitter with with a brand in the tweet
etc etc etc so all those brown as to
build a one-to-one relationship at scale
moreover in this revolution the buying
habits are change a lot in the last five
years with the sharing economy with the
subscription model through slack through
Spotify through Netflix or or sellers
like that so we have more and more limit
less access to consume for consuming
product so things are going more and
more fast concerning payments as well as
loyalty of the customer does not exist
anymore
I mean customer you have today you will
have to convince them again in two years
for example if there is someone having a
tattoo with our leader bitten in the
room just come to see me at the end of
the session I offer you a bottle of
champagne but those kind doesn't exist
anymore
and as well a recent study from eco
Stilton C told us that we have as a
brand less than one second to convince
convince a consumer or to get his
attention so this is the context where
will live as as a brand or as the
companies that sell product or as some
ones that want to attract new customers
and this is a lot of company are not
prepared to to be or to respond to this
endless consumer and less changing
customer so what
what what what we offer or the companies
that can't change or that can adapt well
just instinct extinct let's take for
example Blockbuster DVD here in the US
that disappeared with the Netflix or
let's take the Borders libraries with a
module Amazon so those companies that
are not able to to adapt to this new
customer and those companies that are
not able to make modification every
minute will disappear we usually hear
companies that say oh I'm revamping my
website this is a two years project we
cannot have that anymore
Society or on the revolution we will
live so there is a new way new manner of
consuming and we can say that companies
like Netflix Amazon uber have totally
changed the way we consume and they have
set a limit or they have set a minimum
level for customers that is very high
and all companies need to adapt more
quickly
let's hear a quick example around those
huge companies that succeed they used to
experiment a lot with what we call the
1080 remand rule and with there is a
correlation between number of
experiments you do and your odds of
success as a company this is where a
beat st comes in in order to out brand
and companies to better understand the
user to target them to act directly on
the website on the mobile app to analyze
this traffic and then to optimize the
wall process so we helped company to
make modification every minute every
second on the website and to be the best
at convincing clients so for that we
need to to go in real time and we need
algorithms that will automatically
displays the right version for the right
user so here I just kept an example
around let's take a title of
an article we have to determine in a
second which article which title will be
will be the best for for a user it's
exactly the same for a visual aspect of
a website on a travel website for
example we have only few seconds to
determine if this user would like to
have a travel around luxury staff around
sport or around cultural aspect so we
can adapt the visual on the website so
for all that we implement algorithms
that will display the right version to
the right person
I hope you all plays this game when you
were young but we do exactly the same at
large scale we try to find the right
person and to put in from the right
message and we try to do that in a
second if you take another kind of
personalization we do in real time is to
be able to displace a number of products
which have been bought by the past and
to convince people that they have to buy
this product as well which is the
personalization around product and not
around users and as well we can do less
technical stuff but just inverting steps
in a process of buying or in a process
or subscribing stuff here is an example
we did with UNICEF around inverting 2
steps of their of their form and we
increase the revenue by 818 percent with
them so to quickly tell you about the
company we are we have 750 clients 200
employees 66 countries 14 offices
etcetera etcetera we have 100 Christian
groups yearly since 5 years and we
manage a huge amount of data that Sergey
will explain you in a minute and we work
with huge brands in order to optimize
their websites in real-time all day long
all year long and
we inserted so if your logo is not here
don't hesitate to come to see me at the
end of the session and we will go deeper
in the technical aspect which I guess
that will come on stage to explain you
how did we implement that on on a global
scale level and I did we partner with
Google to marriage that thank you
[Applause]
hi I'm Sergey it's great to be here and
a little about me I'm from Moscow I live
in Paris and I've been with a bit tasty
since 2015
I am also Hadoop ecosystem it was just I
have 12 years of experience working with
back-end architectures I work it'll be
tasty as a head of foundation
essentially I manage the team that works
on all the data processing
infrastructure aspects of our company
and as a part of technical team I'm in
charge of software architecture and
application development and let let me
tell you about the technical evolution
of VB tasty since 2009 and what our next
steps will be so let's dive into this in
2009 what did the Taoiseach technology
stocks look like well remi had the idea
of developing an a/b testing tool and
wanted to move quickly so we built our
proof of concept in one week a
similarity architecture with all the
application database and infrastructure
services on one virtual machine at that
point we only had five small clients
with a small load on our infrastructure
we had a few more 200 emails per second
and we only collected the data related
to our clients campaigns so this
approach work it well until around 2012
when business started to boom
at this point two things started
happening first our clients saw
increasing traffic and second their
expectation increased they wanted higher
functionality and most importantly they
wanted real-time analytics our
monolithic approach was therefore no
longer effective and we started to think
about the right tools to satisfy all
clients we also started to experiment
with the stream data processing and at
this stage we had around 200 clients and
little more than 2,000 events per second
and so in 2016 we tested different tools
which would allow us to improve a
Batista's product and increase
functionality provided us with stability
giving us increase in client traffic and
develop a real-time analytics to meet
client demands we tested a range of
tools as you can see here including
spark stream Kafka Cassandra but we
found they were not adapted to our needs
or cost effective and so in 2017 2018 we
tested the Google cloud platform
and what we really liked was it's open
source approach for me for the developer
and for my team is great in terms of
documentation constant improvement and
so on and also from a business point of
view what Google Analytics does it's
very close to what we do therefore we
can use the same tools as Google
Analytics like bigquery dataflow
BigTable pops up and many others to
reach the same level of performance
which our clients liked and so what is
our approach today thanks to the city
and its data streaming services we have
changed our way of collecting this data
and while we only collected data related
to our clients campaigns
we collect all the we store events which
enables us to develop new insight and so
today we can provide our clients with
some real-time analytics and indicators
and finally let's take a look at our
next steps first we predict that the
number of immens processes per second
will increase 15 fold due to the growth
of EB tasting we expect to be able to
scale our infrastructure accordingly
using second C we have already started
to process our data in different regions
of the world but tomorrow we want to
have the access points ingest and the
storage in different regions also close
to where our clients based such as South
America Australia China many others and
such thing it's a present too many we
provide our clients with insight as to
how to improve their conversion rates
and tomorrow we want to harness machine
learning technology in order to improve
this thank you thank you
so we have a little bit of time and I
actually have some questions in here for
my partners but we would like to hear
from you as well so that's why we save
this time for ourselves to have some
interactions with you your needs and so
forth but to kick this things off and I
think there's mics in here please if you
have mic question please just hop in
there and ask the questions and do we
have any gifts for the best question we
can think of what we can definitely
think of one all right but I do have one
question for both of you so what I
understood is the personalization
matters and those tweaks that you're
making it how does it change the
business how how did it impact from what
it was to what it is today and that the
results that you're seeing as the
business CEO for your customers yeah
at the early beginning of the two small
improvement were very impactful on what
on client websites so just changing the
color of a button was enough or changing
your wording was enough the fact is with
much relief clients with evolution of
website etc we have to be more and more
impactful in what we offer to our
clients and in what our clients offer to
their customer so we have to that's why
we have to implement new features like
image matchmaking which is the fact of
displaying the right image the right
user so we have to find a new way of
catching the attention and I would say
that the increment that we could
generate for our clients is between five
to fifteen percent increase of revenue
during a year so that pretty good I saw
that example for UNICEF does 18 percent
bump it's pretty good
you guys made sure he said what 2019 to
today that's a big change the scale is
impressive so tell us about the volumes
of data that you're seeing how did it
change what happens was the impacts as I
said in my presentation in 2009 we had
our VP built on monolithic architecture
yeah every single data processing
dashboard database was on the same
server and as the business expanded we
built a relational database cluster to
store Lister's data and we used this
approach for about two years but it's
not perfect for our needs and so we
constructed no scale data store
architecture so with some patch spark
jobs in batch mode that we host on
virtual machines and administrate
ourselves and it's were very painful in
terms of maintenance so one year ago we
emigrated over to Google
okay wait six five we had a look
yesterday with a serger about the amount
of data we have and we made a
calculation that every six months we
double the size of the data storage we
up so the increase of volume we ingest
is very important okay very good so I
highlighted several times that batch and
streaming and how having the same set of
cold same sort of tools is important
can you share with our guests in here
what that impact was you know when you
used to do it with batch now you're
doing it real-time streaming and you
don't have to change much of your code
there what was the impact from business
side as well as from your technology
side from a business side it was more
problems than a solution I mean when you
do batch and the time lapse you have to
process the batch is less than the time
you need to process the batch at some
point you are stuck so we are troubled
by trouble to compute this batch and to
and to give a good experience for our
own clients so that's why we try to
stream as much as we could all all the
aspect of the tool and in terms of
personalization that I show you in the
example we cannot do that with better as
we have to be able to categorize the
user and give a new user experience
after the first stage thing by the user
so in batch we cannot do that people
will switch from a first page with a
second page in less than 5 seconds and
we have to calculate that in anything
from your perspective oh yes but for the
clients I think also we can target our
visitors in real time based on the
current behavior when we use the batch
mode and it's complicated
and from a technical point of view for
me batch processing is more painful to
administrate request us to manage job
scheduling and it requires also more
computing crystals and because we
process much more data it wants
okay well thank you
[Music]